quieres hacer esquí de 55 años ser un
veterano en zonas de guerra cubrió
varios conflictos en irak afganistán y
siria trabajaba en ucrania desde febrero
la productora ucraniana del equipo de
fox saia cubs innova murió en el mismo
incidente su colega de foxnews benjamin
jal también está en el hospital resultó
herido después de que fueran atacados
cerca de kiev
la muerte de esas eps key se suma a la
de brandeis reynolds cineasta y
periodista estadounidense que trabajaba
para el new york times' muerto por
disparos de las fuerzas rusas de la
ciudad del ping cerca de la capital
ucraniana el pasado fin de semana
reporteros sin fronteras que presta
apoyo a periodistas y medios de
comunicación afirma que la prensa es
especialmente vulnerable en este
conflicto
it's the liberty
los periodistas son objetivos de ataques
deliberados por parte de algunas tropas
rusas como se ha demostrado en
diferentes ocasiones occasions against
dolor rabia como por ejemplo contra un
equipo de al arabiya news 1 de sky news
un equipo danés y un periodista suizo
así que fue un milagro que ningún
periódico internacional fuera asesinado
antes del sábado no internaciones world
girls before 7 según reporteros sin
fronteras el mayor riesgo lo corren los
numerosos periodistas ucranianos que no
tienen formación en reportajes de guerra
ni el equipo para trabajar y que
intentan ayudar directamente
craig reporteros sin fronteras creó e
inauguró oficialmente el sábado pasado
en la ciudad del ingeniero freedom
center un centro de libertad de prensa
para entregar chalecos antibalas cascos
y herramientas de seguridad a los
periodistas safety
tools
para que podamos empezar a formarlos en
los próximos días
training
según las autoridades ucranianas dos
periodistas ucranianos han muerto desde
el inicio de la invasión rusa el 24 de
febrero uno de ellos yevgueni sakun
murió en el ataque a la torre de
televisión de kiev y el otro víctor
dudar murió en la ciudad portuaria de
mykolaiv al sur del país